one of the big mistakes that i think uh
uh companies make is they think of the
sales goals as the end-all be-all and
they have no higher purpose no higher uh
contribution other than the goal itself
um and so we overuse um uh sort of uh
war and sports analogies to to hit that
goal right it's all very finite thinking
as if it's the end
i like to think of business much more
like a lifestyle um it's much more like
being healthy right the purpose is to be
healthy for example and there are many
things we have to do to be healthy we
have to eat right we have to exercise we
have to get enough sleep uh we have to
nurse our personal relationships there's
probably 30 other things as well it's
the same in business we have to have
good marketing we have good leadership
good product good you know good sales
for us all of these things and it's hard
to maintain all of those things at very
high level all the time they sort of wax
and wane the opportunity is to work hard
it's it's an infinite game to keep those
things um going all the time and it is
perfectly acceptable to set arbitrary
goals
within
uh within that context now most sales
goals are arbitrary somebody sat in an
office and said we're going to hit this
number by this date and so we all went
and did it right which like if you want
to live a healthy lifestyle you say i
want to lose x amount of weight by x
date and you do all the things you have
to do to lose that weight you exercise
you eat right you weigh yourself every
day you met you you count the metrics
metrics are very very healthy people
like metrics if we think about running a
marathon
without mile markers it's actually
unnerving we need to be able to count
our progress to feel like we're moving
forward it's a basic human need and so
we count
we look down at the scale every day some
days we feel good some days we feel bad
and we hit our goal on the right day we
feel amazing like hitting a sales goal
but here's the problem you have to keep
exercising eating and eating right for
the rest of your life you don't get to
stop doing those things and and the
problem in business is we we treat that
goal like it's the end except we have to
keep working on all those things the
good leadership the good sales training
the good culture it has to continue what
i think is more interesting than hitting
the goal
is what happens if you miss the goal
so if you look down at that scale and
you miss your goal you miss the
arbitrary number by that arbitrary date
you know what happens
nothing
nothing happens in fact because you've
been working hard you're actually much
healthier now than where you were
started you just didn't predict the
right day and the right time
and i think what's very very important
if we try and contextualize goal setting
within a purpose-driven company
is to recognize that those numbers and
those dates are not absolute
and if you you look at the trend data i
think it's really important to look at
trend data because there are many teams
who you know their sales are up their
sales are down throughout the year it's
like a roller coaster they have a big
promotion and a big sales push right at
the end of the year they hit their goal
and for some reason we think that that
was good
but if you look at another team where
everything is really steady and really
good morale is high
and and and and things you know but they
just happen to miss the goal but clearly
they're going to hit it two months after
clearly
we give that team nothing
and so i think it's okay to have the
goals it's good to count things but i
think what's what as we move forward and
become more purpose-driven
infinite-minded companies we have to
start including trend data to understand
that it's contextualized like this goal
is designed to advance something bigger
than ourselves